hi
good afternoon everyone uh my name is
priyana trajan
i'm an astrophysicist and serve as the
current director of the frankie program
in science in the humanities at yale i
am delighted to
invite you all to our monthly inference
colloquium series
uh though first i would like to
recognize our benefactors mr and mrs
richard
and barbara frankie who are
on the call today and have joined us and
i also want to remind all of you
that we are recording this event and the
recording is made available
within a week or so and since we are
recording
uh we are required to have all
participants uh mute their videos
and um if you wish uh to participate in
the q a which we
uh encourage we would like you to submit
questions through the chat feature
and feel free to submit your questions
throughout
although we will handle the questions
and
the speaker will address them at the end
of their talk
so um i am absolutely delighted
today to introduce our speaker
professor james owen weatherall who is
a professor of logic and philosophy of
science at the university of california
irvine but he's also a member of the
institute for mathematical behavioral
sciences
and center for cosmology and
as you all know part of the
goal for this series is to really try to
understand
explore and understand issues related to
epistemic
models correlation causation
and we could not have uh a
better uh speaker than today's to
provide
deep insights into what models really
do and over his career he has looked
at a range of questions very very
interesting very topical questions his
most
recent book is titled the misinformation
age how false beliefs spread and
which is co-authored with kailyn
o'connor in which he sort of explores
the social dynamics and the spread if
you will
of belief in evidence-rich environments
and he has several
uh previous books as well one on the
void which is the first one of his that
i
actually read and thoroughly enjoyed
that was published in 2016
by yale university press his current
research interests as i mentioned
uh span a range of very very relevant
issues that have to do with mathematical
and conceptual foundations of physics
philosophy of cosmology
and social epistemology today uh
he will be talking to us about
polarization of beliefs
in particular on issues where at the
gist
life facts in contrast to opinions so
one striking feature as you have all
probably noted
of the current political environment in
the united states and elsewhere
is that there are large groups of people
with extremely divergent beliefs
about what are in fact testable matters
of fact
so these are matters of fact where there
is a rich and widely accessible body of
scientific evidence
that will clearly support one side over
the other
and despite that there is a raging
dispute
and so you know we have all seen this
manifested
in the political environment um with the
elections and the aftermath of the
elections
as well as the unfolding global pandemic
and all the public health and medical
issues that have
arisen around that and we have seen in
many ways
the you know in the context of the
provisional nature of science we've sort
of seen this
interplay of the honing and refining
of facts and data and evidence
and belief formation we've all sort of
had you know front row seat to how some
of these processes occur
especially in this past year in his talk
today
jim will draw on recent modeling work to
provide
three distinct possible explanations for
this polarization in belief
and each of these explanations invokes
very different mechanisms and recommends
different remedies
he will conclude with a discussion of
what it means from the perspective
of epistemology of a model based science
that such different models can produce
such similar outcomes
and the moral of his talk today will be
to caution us against very
overly simplistic explanations and
understand that these are issues of
great complexity and therefore there are
no silver bullet solutions
to our current quandary sort of living
in an environment
which is rampant with misinformation
disinformation
and rampant denial of scientific facts
and i just want to mention that as per
custom
tomorrow we will host a conversation
between
uh professor weatherall and professor
kevin dorst of the department of
philosophy from the university of
pittsburgh
and at the same time so may 26 tomorrow
at 3 p.m
and so we are really really looking
forward uh jim to your talk today
um please take it away and thank you so
much to both of you for
accepting this invitation uh thank you
so much
priya um and uh thank you for your work
in organizing the
the series um i've enjoyed the other
talks and i'm glad to get to participate
so i'm gonna uh share a uh
screen here
um great so uh just gonna jump right in
um uh i'm gonna talk today about
polarization
um and so let me just be clear right up
front what i mean by polarization
because there are a few different
kinds of uh phenomena that
arise in um you know in in this context
that sometimes get this name
so what i have in mind when i talk about
polarization today
is a situation in which you have a
community
of epistemic agents
so by that i mean a community
of people who are trying to
learn about how the world is
and so um polarization arises in such a
community
when the various members of the
community
come to hold beliefs
that diverge from one another uh so i'm
talking about situations where
uh agents come to uh hold divergent
beliefs about matters of fact and i want
to be very clear when i say belief
i'm not talking about religious belief
i'm not talking about
um assertions about values what matters
uh whether something is important or not
um what i'm talking about
are um uh credences
about matters of facts so um the the
amount of confidence that you have that
some assertion about the world
is true or false now
um polarization apparently obtains in
real world situations um
there are uh many examples just we've
seen in the last several years for
instance
um you posed the question was there
widespread voter fraud is widespread is
too fuzzy a word was there voter fraud
at a scale sufficient to influence the
outcome of
the 2020 u.s election um
considerable amounts of polling data
suggests that there really is
a divergent there really are divergent
beliefs
um in the the u.s population about that
question
um with a great deal of confidence on
both sides about what the the facts are
so this is the kind of situation that i
have in mind
um and uh um i'm focusing here as priya
mentioned in the introduction on cases
where
it's not just that there are these
disagreements but in fact there appears
to be
information available to the community
that
um bears on uh uh the uh the situation
in the sense that
um there should be evidence there's
evidence available um
prima facie it appears that that
evidence ought to be sufficient to
settle
the issue one way or the other and yet
nonetheless it doesn't seem as if
uh consensus emerges
okay and so what i'm going to do today
is uh
talk about three different models in
which polarization
is a possible outcome these are
agent-based models in which
i um uh will describe how
um sort of very simplified setting
idealized agents
um gather information about the world
and share that information
and then update their beliefs in light
of that information
and uh show that in each of these models
um polarization is a possible outcome
now each of these models can be
understood
to suggest a prima facie plausible
explanation of real world polarization
these are the kinds of explanations
that you sometimes see theorized
um as the explanation for actual real
world
polarization but as i'll discuss
each of the models differs in the kind
of explanation that they offer
and in the the the details of the
conditions under which you should expect
polarization to appear
um and then so you know most of the talk
is going to be discussing these various
models and what kinds of explanations of
polarization they suggest
but i'm going to conclude by thinking
about
some issues in philosophy of modeling
about what we can infer from this
situation what we can infer from the
fact
that a single phenomenon a single social
phenomenon in this case can be
plausibly modeled in such different ways
i want to acknowledge my uh collaborator
so i'm going to be discussing three
different papers two of which
have appeared in print one of which is
unpublished um
kailyn o'connor is a co-author on all of
these papers
um also co-author of the book that priya
mentioned misinformation age
where some of these results are
discussed
okay so we discussed the um the
modeling methodology briefly so as i
said i'm going to discuss here
agent-based models
um i want to emphasize these are highly
idealized
models uh these are not meant to provide
a uh
fully accurate um a complete
representation
of any kind of human activity
they're supposed to abstract some
particular
collection of salient features that
one might ask whether so where one might
ask whether those features
are sufficient under some circumstances
to bring about some sort of qualitative
uh phenomenon um and so
um we're reasoning with highly abstract
and highly idealized models
um i'm going to describe how the models
work so hopefully you'll you'll get a
sense of how this
works but i just want to flag up front
that we aren't trying to give
uh various similitudinous
representations of um the the
actual you know social world here we're
doing something a little bit different
from that
um two of the models that i'm going to
uh discuss are within the same
modeling framework known as the network
epistemology framework
and then the third considers individual
bayesian learning
now each project establishes conditions
under which polarization may emerge
now i absolutely do not want to suggest
that these are
uh the only models in which this happens
or the most important models in which
this happens
or um anything like that um
their representative in a sense uh
but i'm describing some of the models
that i've worked on um there are many
many other
models some very similar some very
different from the ones i'm going to
discuss
that um lead to very similar sorts of
uh arguments and observations
um okay good
so um i'm gonna begin by giving sort of
an overview of the
the framework in which the first two
models uh
lives um the network epistemology
framework
i'm then going to um introduce two
versions to network epistemology models
that uh
um uh i'm i'm gonna discuss one based on
what i'm to call trust dynamics
one based on what i'm going to call
conformity then i'm going to introduce
the
the third model which works in a
somewhat different
framework and discuss how
that can be used to understand some
aspects of journalistic
practices and then i'm going to conclude
with a discussion of what we can learn
from this modeling situation
so to begin network epistemology
so to build the models in the first two
of uh
these parts of the talk we work in a
framework that was
um originally developed by two uh
economists uh venkatesh bala and
uh sanjiv goyal they were working
with an audience of economists in mind
uh but their work was
adapted to the philosophy of science
context
uh about 15 years ago now by
kevin zulman who's the uh the one on the
far
left there and so um since then
there's been a a community of people
working in philosophy of science
using this sort of framework to try to
understand various aspects
of the social spread of evidence and
belief
within epistemic communities generally
and
specifically within scientific
communities
so the way these these models work
is that you have um a decision problem
so basically you're trying to to choose
between two
possible actions um we're going to call
one action a
the other one action b now the setup
here is that action a and action b
when they succeed provide the same
payoff
but they succeed at different rates and
so
you're uncertain about which one has a
higher expected value because you're
uncertain about
which one succeeds at the higher rate
so we're going to assume here that in
fact one of these actions
has been well studied and all of the
agents are confident
that that action is uh succeeds at a
rate of of 0.5 so half the time it
succeeds it gives payoff one
half the time it fails and it gives no
payoff
but they're uncertain about the rate at
which the other action
action b succeeds and they're trying to
learn
about whether action b has a higher
expected value or a lower expected value
um by testing that right there they're
performing
the idea is that they perform uh uh
the various actions they learn based on
what happens when they do perform the
actions they update their beliefs about
which action is better
and so there's a whole community trying
to converge to
all act in the way that yields the
higher expected value
now this is a very simple problem of
course there's certain kinds of
scientific situations
that have this qualitative feature so
for instance
you might think about a situation where
a new medication is introduced and
if that medication succeeds it has the
outcome that a patient is
um survives and if it fails the patient
does not survive
you can have two you know you're trying
to compare now is this new medication
more or less successful than some
existing medication
whose success rate is well known
um one thing that's that's nice about
this particular kind of example is
they're pretty high stake so you want to
perform whatever action you think is the
the better one even though you're of
course very very interested in learning
uh from others whether or not perhaps
the other action turns out
to be better after all
okay and so um this is the problem that
our our agents are trying to solve
we represent the agents as having
credences so these credences
can be represented as a single number
between zero and one we can think of
that as the probability
that the agent each agent assigns
to the proposition that b is better
now i i should um say in all of these
models we're just adopting a convention
that in fact
b is better this is important because
there really is a better
outcome um you know there's a fact of
the matter there's some
some truth here that we can know about
outside the model and which we can
observe now how the agents
uh learn how successfully they are at
learning about
um uh whether or not b is in fact better
okay and so um the agents uh
uh are arranged on a network so the idea
is that
each agent in each round of a simulation
is understood to perform an action they
perform the action that they think is
better
some number of times
um so if they're then the number
that represents their credence is
greater than 0.5 they perform action b
if it's less than 0.5
they perform action a some number of
times
after doing that you can think of this
as a kind of
performing an experiment you you get
some sample
um and could be one but it could be
greater than one so you could
perform the action several times think
of that as the results of an experiment
and now
you take that data and each agent
updates their belief in light of that
data
using bayes rule okay
now in addition to updating based on
their own data
this is where the network structure
comes in right this is why this is
network epistemology
in addition to updating uh
their beliefs based on their own data
all of the agents also update their
beliefs
based on the data generated by their
immediate neighbors
and so what happens here is that you
have
at least to begin with uh different
agents in the network performing
the two different actions but then in
general
uh all or or many of the agents
receiving information not only about
what they think is the better action but
also
what their neighbors think is the better
action this way they can update on
on both kinds of actions and eventually
they converge to um
some sort of outcome okay now
um this basic model as i've just
described it is one in which
generally authors have found that
communities
converge towards consensus that is
either all of the agents converge
to having very high confidence that
action b is in fact better
an outcome that we'll call true
consensus so um
uh consensus about the truth
the other possibility is that the agents
all erroneously settle on the worst
action
a now but because of the structure of
this model
um you're you're going to get one or the
other so basically what's going to
happen is eventually all of the agents
are going to be performing action b
which is in fact better and
overall the data is going to tend to
keep their beliefs that b
is better high or what's going to happen
is that all of them are going to come to
believe that a is better and no one will
perform
action b anymore until you end up with a
stable outcome where no new information
about action b
is gathered because everyone has decided
that the
the worse action is uh better
okay so that that's the the the basic
model that we're going to be working
with
the first two parts of this talk here
um now i'm going to discuss the first of
two
modifications to this model that
introduced
some component that might be understood
to explain
polarization okay so this is based on a
paper that caitlin and i wrote
that was published in the european
journal for philosophy of science a few
years ago called scientific polarization
so in this model what we do is we begin
with the same network epistemology model
that uh i discussed
but we modify how
agents update in light of evidence
produced by other agents
so agents still update in light of their
own evidence in the same way
but they update in light of
other agents evidence in a different way
the idea here that the motivation for
this
is that we suppose that agents
take some evidence to be of higher
quality
than others um and
uh the higher quality evidence they're
going to to take
they're going to be very confident in
lower quality evidence they're going to
be
less confident so how do they determine
what kind of evidence to be confident in
um
well of course there are various ways in
which you can imagine very complicated
high rationality sorts of strategies for
figuring this out
um here we suppose just a very simple
one
which is that um the agents take
the data generated by people who
disagree with them
to be less trustworthy
now why would you do that uh so
one idea here is that um in
if you're evaluating someone's
information the information that someone
is sharing with you
and you think okay this is an epidemic
process
they've somehow gathered this data
i'd like to try to evaluate how good
they are as epistemic ajax
how likely are they to come to good
conclusions
collect data reliably and so on um and
i'm going to
use their past epistemic success by my
own lights
to evaluate that and so the idea is that
if i look around and i see
well these people uh according to the
data that i have access to
and and the beliefs that i hold appear
to have succeeded
in their epistemic tasks i'm going to
assume that the data they're sharing
with me
is more reliable and the people who
by my own lights appear to have failed
at their epistemic tasks
i'm going to understand to likely be
producing
data that's less reliable now i'm still
going to treat that data
in general as something i could update
on
but i'm going to treat it as less
certain
so here's the idea um i
am going to um model trust here
as a um
an assignment of uncertainty
to the amount sorry assignment of
uncertainty to the data produced
by other agents
where the amount of uncertainty
is described by some function that
decreases
with the distance between my beliefs
and the agent who's produced the data's
beliefs
and so the idea here is that an agent
who um
if someone produces evidence that is um
sorry if someone holds beliefs that are
very distant from mine whatever evidence
they produce
i'm gonna treat that as uh more
uncertain
than uh evidence produced by someone who
is closer to my own beliefs
now um the updating rule that we use
here i i didn't write it down on the
slide but it's a standard
updating rule and alternative to bayes
rule for
um updating beliefs in light of evidence
known as
jeffrey conditionalization which is the
standard way of updating beliefs in
light of
uncertain evidence and so what's going
on here is we're treating
uh evidence produced by others as
uncertain evidence
with some degree of uncertainty that's
determined by
this function now i'll just note that
this kind of strategy um so using
jeffrey conditionalization
uh to model this i believe is original
to this paper
but the the basic kind of strategy where
you
conditionalize how you
uh how agents update their beliefs or
their opinions
based on some function of
the distance between their beliefs or
opinions
uh is widespread in the literature this
is something that's been been studied at
least since the early 2000s
um and uh and so what we're doing is
adapting
this kind of um this kind of mechanism
uh to the network epistemology framework
and introducing the idea that
jeffrey conditionalization is a um
a useful way of of modeling
now i'll just note that we have to
introduce some decreasing
function uh of the distance between
agents beliefs to do this
we consider several different ones just
a linear function exponential
um uh and some others
and the qualitative results don't don't
depend on that
as long as it's a strictly decreasing
function um we get
qualitatively the same results and the
qualitative results are really what
we um we take to be trustworthy here or
in any way
you know the relevant output of the mod
okay so what are the results of this
well first
there's a new possibility now the new
possibility
is that for certain values
of this parameter
m which governs uh how
strongly agents tend to distrust
other agents um
we can begin to see polarization so
when that parameter exceeds a certain
value
conventionally set to one uh in the
model as we've set it up
we see polarization which are stable
outcomes where some agents
have high credence that b is better and
some
have low credence that b is better i.e
they believe that a is better
and moreover it's stable because the
agents
don't trust one another they've come to
occupy to
be distant enough from one another in
belief space
that the agents that are performing
action b
and um producing evidence that
the better action is in fact better uh
no longer influence the agents who
uh believe that age that action a is
better
right and so what happens is although
lots of evidence is being produced
and loss of evidence is being shared
you've gotten to a situation
where the agents are so distant from one
another that they don't trust one
another
and they don't update in light of the
evidence
that's shared by the other group
and um one way of thinking about what
happens here is as
m becomes larger and larger the
um the the distance in belief
but that needs to be achieved in order
for
this um or failure of listening
to occur gets smaller and smaller
and so the idea is that you know there's
there's some parameter here that's going
to govern how that works
um and so here's a chart that shows how
how that happens in the model
um as i said before m equals one
is conventionally set as the the value
of the parameter for which
uh it's even possible for them to stop
listening to one another as opposed to
merely
treating each other's evidences uh very
uncertain but still
updating on it um and so as you see as
m gets larger various sizes of networks
what we see is that polarization
becomes increasingly likely um
and once m gets up to two or a little
bit higher
you begin to see polarization in all or
nearly all
runs okay
good um just note that it's not just
that
that um sort of this parameter m doesn't
just increase polarization it also
increases
the uh the total number of false beliefs
that are held by
a community and so what you see here are
plots of average outcomes across
a large range of different parameter
values different values of n
different values of the number of agents
in the network
and so on different values of epsilon
how hard a problem it is how how big
is the difference an expectation value
between action and action b
and what you see is across all those
different parameters as
m increases the
fraction of the network
that ends up holding false beliefs
increases um and so
you're going to see different fractions
depending on the different other
parameters but each of these lines is
higher than the one before
okay so there's lots more that i could
say about this model but the point is to
describe several models so
let me move on and just point to some of
the takeaways from this model
that are going to be important in the
discussion that follows
so i think the first takeaway is just
that polarization can apparently occur
under these sorts of circumstances that
is it can occur in an episomic community
with certain kinds of properties in
which agents tend to distrust evidence
produced by some agents
where that distrust is conditioned on
their difference in belief
now in the present model
uh the i the phenomenon is driven by the
fact that agents
explore i.e perform the action
that they think is better and so it's
the people who believe b is better who
are performing
action b who are generating data about
action being
and it's precisely those agents that
are ignored by or distrusted by the ones
who hold the false belief the one to
think that action a is better um
and so what's happening here is that uh
distrust is preventing the reliable
information from reaching the people
who would need it to
reach more reliable uh
beliefs so you might think of this as
possibly a way of modeling certain kinds
of
um certain kinds of uh vaccine hesitancy
where um uh some people are
believe that the vaccines you'll say a
copy vaccine is
safe and effective other people think um
it hasn't been shown to be safe or it
hasn't been shown to be effective
um there's a lot of data now population
level
data uh hundreds of millions of people
across the world who have received this
vaccine
good data on what their outcomes have
been so far
but if that data isn't trusted by the
people who are skeptical for various
reasons maybe they think it's
manipulated maybe they think
that people are trying to mislead them
or have some ulterior motive
they're not going to update their
beliefs and light up that data even
though it's present
so um i just want to say once again uh
this is a particular model but in fact
this is consonant with a very large
literature
discussing um especially what's
sometimes known as opinion dynamics
uh in the case where um
agents condition how their beliefs
change on
the distance between their belief or
their opinion
and that of other agents so
this is a widely studied phenomenon it's
one common possible explanation
that you see in um the mathematical
social sciences literature
for how polarization might arise
okay now i'm going to switch gears we're
going to talk about another network
epistemology model
one that invokes a different mechanism
to explain
polarization um which i'm going to call
conformity
once again this is uh based on a paper
that uh kailyn and i
wrote together uh
kayla doesn't like this paper as much as
she let me be first author on this one
okay so conformity so there's a very
long literature in social psychology
that um experimental literature that
that documents
a tendency of of human subjects to
conform
with members of their social group
um the ash experiments in particular is
one where
uh you have a subject um
in a group where the other groups are
are not experimental subjects but are
um uh members of the research team
and what happens is the um the whole
group are shown
a number of pictures right so you have a
line and then two other lines with
um or two or three other lines anyway
you're showing a line you're showing
some other lines and you're asked is
this first line
uh the same length as one of these other
ones
and um the various uh
research group participants i mean the
ones who are are not subjects
uh say that um
something that's obviously false that
you know this line which is clearly the
the same length as this other line is
longer
and then the the research subject is uh
asked
to uh to give their opinion on this
and you find that in a significant
number of
uh cases they will go along with the
group
despite the uh the fact that just
the evidence of their senses right the
the fact that it's obviously the case
um that uh uh the group has
um the other members of the group have
expressed some
false view um okay so
given that tendency we might try to
introduce conformity
into a network epistemology framework
as follows so the idea here is that
when you're making a decision about what
action to perform
um you might be thinking about the
payoff you'll get from performing that
action
but you might also be considering some
other preferences that will enter into
an expected value calculation
and so um one such preference might be
a desire to conform your actions
to the actions of your neighbors
so um we model this
by adding a conformity parameter which
tracks
how much payoff actors get simply from
matching their behaviors to those of
their network neighbors
now um we once again adopt a very
low rationality model here we aren't um
you know each agent isn't trying to
model the beliefs or likely actions of
the other agents around them all they're
doing is they're saying well what did
people do in the last round
um if uh um most people
did action a then i'm going to expect to
get
a payoff from conforming to action a
um and what i in order to choose to do
action b i need to not only believe that
action b
is better but i also need it to be the
case
that um the benefits that i i get
by you know the good feeling i get
by conforming to all of my neighbors
doing action a
uh has to overcome the benefits of
performing action b
okay and so the idea here is that we're
going to weigh two different desires a
desire to choose accurate actions and
get the payoffs
that come with that and a desire to
conform
with neighbors now
when we introduce this we once again
like with uh the trust dynamics um begin
to see new possible outcomes
for the model so simulations can still
approach
either true consensus or false consensus
those are still possible outcomes
but um another possible outcome that
doesn't exist in the base model
it's a situation where uh the network
may can converge to a situation where
everyone performs the same
action even though
some agents secretly believe that the
other action is better
but they don't perform the other action
um because they prefer to convert
to conform and because they don't
perform the other action
no new evidence regarding the
superiority of the other action
uh is introduced into the network and so
although um there are uh
there's some diversity of belief here
it's not reflected
in the data that's generated and shared
in the network
um and uh uh
we we call that situation um we have two
different names one is true disagreement
and false disagreement so true
disagreement is a situation where
everyone's performing the better action
but there's disagreement still the other
situation is where
everyone's performing the worst action
they're performing action a
even though some people um believe that
action b
is better now finally we can uh
find an outcome where you get
polarization and action
and belief so the idea here is that
um under some circumstances
specifically in the presence of certain
network structures
what can happen is that one group
comes to believe that action a is better
and they all perform action a
and another group comes to believe that
action b
is better and they'll perform action b
but the information doesn't pass
effectively between the groups so
to see how this depends on network
structure let me introduce a few
basic network structures so um consider
lots of different things
um the cycle the wheel the com
complete network these are standard
networks to consider we're not going
they're not that important for our
purposes the ones that are important for
our purposes or what happens when you
have a randomly generated network
using various different kinds of
algorithms for generating networks
or in particular you look at networks
that you might describe as clumpy
or having clicks so the idea here is
that
uh polarization is going to appear
specifically in cases
where networks have a click structure
so how does this work well the idea is
if you have a click here is defined as a
group of agents
that are tightly connected to one
another
but only weakly connected to other
groups of asians who are in turn
mutually tightly connected to one
another as we see in this case we have
two separate complete networks that are
linked only by a single
edge and so the way in which
polarization can appear here
is that in one of these clicks
uh everyone comes to believe action b is
better they perform action b
um and they they that sort of mini
network
uh approaches a true consensus whereas
in the other click
everyone comes to perform action a
and almost all of them believe that
action a is better
but in fact the one agent in this
picture
who has access to the information from
the other click
will generally over time come to update
on that information come to believe that
in fact action b
is better but because of their
preference to conform
and there's only one action b doer in
their immediate network but there are
many action a
doers in their immediate network they
never switch their action
but because they're a kind of bridge for
this information
because they never switch their action
the other agents in their click
never receive data showing that action b
is better so the picture is one where
that that agent uh conforming
um sort of blocks the spread of reliable
information
into their click
and so you can see uh different kinds of
outcomes
here depending on how strong this
conformity parameter is basically
the conformity parameter is just a
measure of how how strong the preference
is
for um conforming your actions to those
of your neighbors
what you see is that um
you know as conformity increases correct
consensus
still tends to be uh more likely
correct disagreement is the the next
most likely outcome
and then you start seeing these uh
incorrect consensus and incorrect
disagreements
but then you have this very small
likelihood here
of getting polarization but that you
know how big that likelihood is depends
on just what your
network structure is and so if we look
at specifically different network
structures
we see different results and so
um especially in the case of high
conformity which is the uh the plot on
the uh
the left here unless i'm mirrored in
which case it's the plot on the right
um the one that's labeled high
conformity
what you see is that in the clumpy case
right this case with the strong click
structure
uh nearly half of all outcomes are
polarized outcomes
um and so uh if you have a network that
has that structure
then you can expect polarization to
occur
simply due to conformity without needing
any other explanation
so what can we take away from this well
in the presence of certain network
structure
conformity provides another sufficient
cause for polarization
and that's because of this this
mechanism whereby you get bottlenecks as
i described
now if you're thinking well i mean how
realistic
are these sorts of uh clumpy networks
well the answer is that in fact um uh
research empirical research on um all
sorts of
real human social networks from the
structure
of uh facebook networks to
studies of sort of ordinary um offline
populations
suggests that real social networks have
a characteristic known as
a small world property which means that
um uh agents tend
to have few connections but to have a
very short
path length between them and anyone else
is sometimes called the kevin bacon
effect
where um uh jim is this
uh jim are these also referred to as
bubbles
or is that slightly different so that's
that's slightly different this this
this predates the idea of uh your filter
bubbles
um by uh decades
yeah so this is just a general result in
in network theory that you can describe
small world networks and then it turns
out to be an empirical fact that you
have these sorts of small world networks
and
in real real situations where and
they're called small worlds because
so the the small world metaphor isn't
supposed to be one where you think
we have these these isolated worlds that
are distinct from one another like
little
worlds rather it's the small world
phenomenon like who would have known
that you knew so and so um or that you
were just two or three connections away
from so-and-so
now i don't remember the number exactly
but it's something like uh on average
the average path length between random
facebook
um uh um
members is uh very very low it's like
four or five
um and so you know the average path
length for information to spread
to anywhere in the network uh is
surprisingly short
um but the point is that these small
world networks are ones that have clicks
um and if you um
there's a standard algorithm for
generating small world networks
generating random small world networks
known as the strogatz watts algorithm
if you use that algorithm to generate
your networks using that random networks
with this conformity dynamics
you find polarization at a
much higher rate than in the other sort
of more uniform networks
that uh i introduced um
okay so this is another kind of
possible explanation for polarization
having to do with
uh the network structure of human
interaction
let me now introduce uh yet another
model with a totally different
framework and mechanism now this last
paper is a work in progress
um it's collaborative with kailyn but
also with uh
one of our graduate students uh aiden
mohsen
okay so the last two models considered
social factors um as the ways in which
people update on evidence
from other agents and um uh
change their behavior in light of the
behavior of other agents
uh to explain how polarization can
appear um in this model
we're going to to look just at
individuals who are
engaged in kind of a bayesian learning
activity based on a stream of data
generated by some outside source
and we're going to understand this this
data generated by the outside source to
represent
information that they receive from some
media
so you can think about this as applying
to different kinds of cases you can
think about it as applying to
uh you know traditional news media
or you can think about as applying to
social media but the idea is that
there's some
some process by which the data that they
see is
generated by some intermediary the data
that they see is somehow curated
by some some something between them in
the world
um and the idea is that there's a
curation process that involves some
practice use right so some processes
involved
in choosing what data of all the data
that's
that's sort of generated in the world um
agents actually update on what we're
going to ask is how
those practices interact with individual
reasoning biases to influence belief
so here's the basic picture
news media do not report on all events
in the domain
some events are selected for coverage so
how do you choose
which events to cover now
if you look at actual practice you look
at um
norms for how journalists should
practice you see various criteria
um described that are applied
to select which of the events are going
to be reported on
right and so just as an example it's a
you know classic adage of uh
journalism you don't report on dog bites
man
you report on man bites dog right so you
report on the things that are unusual or
unexpected or perhaps extreme events
right the biggest hurricane you know the
worst hurricane season the you don't
report on every earthquake
you report on the ones that are above a
certain uh
threshold on the richter scale um
another example of a criterion that
might be applied
the long-standing norm in uh journalism
which in the u.s was actually
um part of a official fcc policy until
the 1980s
that um and joins journalists previously
required journalists
to report fairly now this idea of
fair reporting was given a particular
um characterization the idea was that
if you ever reported on some
controversial matter
you would need either within your story
or elsewhere within
your organization to also give equal
time
to other sides of that issue
and so even to this day um usa today for
instance if they
run a an editorial on a controversial
topic they always pair it with an
editorial
supporting the opposite position but you
also see
within just regular articles
an expectation that the other side will
be described it will be given some
um some space to express their views
okay so these are two different examples
of what i mean by
criteria that may be applied to select
which events are reported
so how are we going to model this well
here's the idea the idea is that
um there's some
range of events that occur in the world
think of it maybe as um storms
and the storms are sampled from some
normal distribution w right so you can
think of this the severity of the storm
as just being some
um something that that is randomly
generated um
sampled from some random variable
distributed according to this normal
distribution w
with fixed mean and fixed standard
deviation
now journalists aren't going to cover
every storm that happens what they're
going to do is they're going to select
from this initial distribution
which events to cover and you can think
of this
as a process by which the distribution w
is transformed into another distribution
which you could call a reported
distribution
r which generally differs from w
okay and so now we have some agents who
are interested in learning about how the
world is
but they're getting their information
from journalists and so what they're
doing is they're updating their beliefs
on data that's randomly sampled from
this new distribution are the
distribution
of reported events and what we're
interested in
is how does their posterior distribution
how does the the bayesian agent's
beliefs
about the world differ from the
distribution of actual events
in particular we're going to assume that
the underlying process
we can take the agents to assume that
the underlying process is gaussian
with unknown mean and variance they're
going to assume interchangeability and
what we're going to do is normal
uh model their beliefs with what's known
as normal inverse gamma distribution
now the important thing here is just um
that distribution
allows them to calculate an expected
value for
the mean of w and an expected value
for the standard deviation or the
variance of w
and what's going to happen is we're
going to be able to compare those
expected values for the mean and the
variance with the actual mean and
variance of w
okay and so we're going to assume that w
is some normal distribution
it's got some fixed mean and variance um
the mean mu
in general can uh be off zero and so
we're gonna
assume that there's some social neutral
point sort of what you know
um uh uh what people take
um you know what journalists i should
say
take to be the uh um sort of
common knowledge about you know where
things are on average but the actual
distribution is going to be um
and maybe uh deviate from that
and now we're going to consider a few
different processes by which the
reported distribution
r is constructed so one
hyperbole journalists just exaggerate
so um sometimes yeah so what happens is
you know
x occurs they report some factor h times
x you know it's the biggest storm
the worst hurricane the biggest uh
earthquake even if it isn't
really the biggest um
okay and so we have some parameter h
that governs how that works
here's another process um extremity
journalists only report on events that
lie some distance
from the neutral point and so
um this is again like i'm not going to
report on every earthquake i'm only
going to
report on the ones that exceed some
value uh
on the richter scale um and then the
final one is fair reporting which i
discussed before
and the way that we're going to model
that here is that every time you have an
event
that journalists want to report on on
one side of the neutral point
they need to look for another event that
represents the other side so every time
they
report on one side they report on the
other side as well
now they're always reporting real events
they're just pairing them in a way where
every event on one side corresponds to
event on the other
now we're also we also consider
distributions that result from combining
these we look at each of these
individually we combine them in various
ways
now just to give you a sense of what
this does
each of these transformations can be
understood
to produce a distribution and so if we
start with
our distribution w labeled here as the
objective distribution
what hyperbole does is sort of flatten
that distribution but also shift its
mean a little bit away from the uh
um the neutral point zero um
what extremity bias does is it just cuts
out
part of the events so not all of the
events are reported just the
the tales um and then fair reporting
uh does this thing where
um you basically take the part of the
distribution
uh on each side of the
neutral point and you
normalize it so that the probability of
being on one side or on the other
is 0.5 right that corresponds to pairing
these events
um but you do it in such a way that
um you're only you're keeping the shape
of the distribution the same
you're just rescaling so that the total
area underneath the distribution to the
left of zero is equal to that to the
right of zero
and so what sorts of results do we see
here well
an agent updating on data sampled from r
converges to a posterior distribution
that approximates r right so we're just
approximating each of these
distributions as a normal distribution
in general these are going to differ
from the true distribution
um you can that you know error with
respect to the mean or the variance
but um you're gonna be able to see these
as a pretty
um straightforward approximation of
the reported uh evidence
so what you see then is that well the
way you get the most reliable beliefs is
just by reporting on the true
distribution of evidence
so here's just an example of this sort
of
uh cognizant of time here i'm timing
myself i've been going for 52 minutes
but
i started a little bit late and i know
that it's one now so i'm going to uh
pick up the pace a little bit here um
so here's an example of this
um you have some true distribution of
evidence you then have a reported
distribution of events
combining some of these different uh
distortions
and then you end up with some posterior
uh this is the one on the uh the pink
one here
some posterior distribution that
approximates with a normal distribution
the reported evidence
okay so
now let's consider the following
addition to this model
we suppose that instead of updating on
all of the data that journalists produce
um agents uh have
a cognitive bias they have a tendency
to prefer
to update on data that is
consistent with their existing beliefs
so this is known as confirmation bias
where individuals seek out evidence that
supports their existing beliefs they
ignore
evidence that conflicts with them or
alternatively sometimes
they reinterpret evidence that conflicts
with their beliefs
as uh supporting their beliefs when they
when it doesn't
so here's how we're gonna implement this
idea we're gonna suppose that there's
some probability for any reported event
that the agent
uh updates on that event um but that
probability is going to be less than one
and is going to be a decreasing function
of the distance between data and the
agent's expectation for the mean result
so one way of thinking about this is the
probability
of updating on data that
the agent thinks is very likely is going
to be higher
than the probability of updating on data
that the agent thinks
is very unlikely
okay so what happens when we introduce
this modification
well it turns out that when with this uh
modification once again based on very
well documented psychological
behavior in real people we get a very
different kind of outcome
now what happens is instead of trying to
approximate
the whole distribution of reported
events with the gaussian
what we find is that agents tend to con
converge
to a gaussian centered at or near
one of the modes of the reported
distribution in particular whichever
mode
is closest to their prior expected me
so what this means is that for bimodal
reported distributions which can occur
when you have um extremity bias or when
you have
fair and balanced reporting um
you can come up with situations you find
situations where
uh agents that have priors on one side
converge to the mode closest to them
whereas asians that have beliefs on the
other side
converge to the node that's closest to
them
and these are going to generally be
different from one another and in fact
what you can see is that over time
beliefs can actually diverge from one
another priors that are close to one
another
can uh uh become more distant
with more data um and the reason that
happens is
even though the mo the the priors are
initially close to one another
nonetheless one is closer to one mode
and the other closer to the other mode
and they approach the modes of the
reported distribution
so here's a figure that shows that
happening you have some true
distribution of evidence
you have here some combination of
extremity bias and
fair reporting that leads to some
distorted um reported
distribution of evidence and what you
find is in these these two different
uh charts on the right the two pink ones
um agents that
um begin with slightly different priors
where you see that that in both cases
their their uh
their priors are um they're less certain
than they end up being the priors the
the um more the less opaque
um gaussian what you see is that
although they start kind of close to one
another over time
they separate and moreover their
confidence becomes
a much greater i.e their expected value
for
the standard deviation of the events in
the world
becomes um smaller
and so neither agent ends up
approximating the true distribution of
events very well
um they both have smaller variants in
the true distribution of events and they
get the mean wrong
okay so this is the kind of polarization
right it's a polarization where
agents with different priors um
presented with the same evidence end up
with different posteriors um and what's
driving this result is
the way that we've modeled confirmation
bias along with the way in which
the evidence is presented
what happens is in cases where there's
little or no data that lies between the
two modes
agents don't get pulled towards the true
central behavior
right so they never end up approximating
w
because all they ever see or all they
ever actually update on
is data that lies near one of the two
modes
now i think you know it's not really the
point of the talk today i just want to
flag though one very interesting result
of this work
is that hyperbole which i think is is
arguably the only of these biases that
we really consider
problematic uh generally speaking
or at least incompatible with good
journalistic practice
um actually doesn't contribute to
polarization
unless you also have fairness and
extremity bias um
and uh extremity bias especially to a
lesser extent now fairness
um do conform with journalistic norms
um i think that it's it's not considered
problematic
for journalists to report only on
things that are considered interesting
or novel or
out of an ordinary
okay so again in the interest of time
i'm going to do this
briefly but i can ask now what do these
models taken together
tell us about the real world phenomenon
of polarization
which model is right now
i think that there's a tempting line of
thought here
just to think about this sort of
situation in a way analogous to how you
might think about
a scientific theory so the idea here is
you come up with some model that model
reproduces some qualitative phenomenon
you might take that fact as primo fascia
evidence that some feature of the model
actually describes how some aspect of
how
say a social situation or social group
functions right this is a move that's
very similar to a standard inferential
pattern
often attributed to scientists whereby
if you have a theory
that makes some prediction say about the
outcomes of some experiment or
the tendency of some phenomenon to occur
and then you find that that phenomenon
occurs
you infer that the theory must be true
or approximately true or you increase
your credence that that particular
theory
is accurate um
now there's a well-known defeater for
this sort of reasoning
which is a situation in which you have
sometimes called under determination
of theory by evidence that is you have
um many different theories that are
apparently
equally compatible with the observed
data
so in a case like that if you have
different theories that explain the data
and you don't have a way of choosing
between them you might say well
that mean that undermines my my
confidence in any of them
so you might think that the right moral
to draw
from models of the sort that i've just
discussed is that look these models
can't tell us anything
about how real world polarization works
we can't infer anything from them they
disagree about the underlying mechanism
they provide different explanations
um and that means that we can't choose
between them
and if we can't choose between them that
means that we can't for instance
use them to make any kinds of policy
recommendations we can't use them
to um think about you know how we got
into a particular epistemic situation
how we might get out of it
we can't use them to to reason
effectively about
the world as we find it and so you might
think then this
that that really what we need to
understand real world polarization
is something something very different so
maybe some combination of
fine-grained empirical evidence
something that can can really
distinguish these cases from one another
help us understand what's really going
on
um now maybe there's still a role for
models of the sort or
perhaps actually successor models that
um
are you know attempt to model the world
with greater
um detailed accuracy
um because then you might think well
what the models can do is come up with
more
specific and discriminating predictions
that we could then use to
distinguish between the possible
explanations of polarization
presented by each of these models
now i want to suggest that that is not
at all the right moral to draw
from this situation but in fact we can
draw much stronger
and more important morals from uh
the the models as presented and why is
that
well the kind of dialectic i just
presented
seems to take for granted that if these
models disagree about the underlying
cause of polarization
then they are incompatible right and
this is the sort of thing you might
think to be true
if uh you're talking about say theories
in physics
where different theories you know if you
have two different theories of the
electron you might think only one of
them can be right
and so if both of them reproduce the
data you have you don't have a way of
choosing between them even though
you know only one of them could be
correct but that's not what's going on
here
it's not the case that these different
mechanisms are incompatible
rather i think what we see here
is that there are apparently multiple
sufficient causes
for the social phenomenon of
polarization now i
as i said at the beginning i don't at
all mean to suggest that what i've given
here
is an exhaustive list or even the most
important examples
of possible causes of polarization
i just claim that these are models that
suggest
that a certain kind of mechanism
may be sufficient for polarization
all of these mechanisms can be present
together
right it can be that we have
confirmation bias in fact it appears we
do have confirmation bias
and it may be that we have conformity
bias and in fact it appears we do have
conformity bias
and it may be that we tend to trust some
source of evidence more than others and
perhaps
we condition based on um the epistemic
success
of the uh the originator of the evidence
which apparently is something
that we do do so all of these can be
operative at the same time
now what that means is that even if you
had more fine-grained empirical
data and predictions
that tried to distinguish between the
different models
the fact that you could get good
evidence
that one of these mechanisms is present
and is leading to polarization
does not imply that the other ones are
not
also present and also contributing to
polarization
so in fact i think that the right way of
thinking about what's going on here
is that we see that evidence for
a particular hypothesis here about what
causes polarization
isn't evidence against other alternative
you might have thought competing but in
fact complementary
explanations of polarization and so
um i take that to uh
be the the basis for a strong cautionary
note
about how to think about policy making
um
intended to um uh
somehow ameliorate polarization
particularly say polarization and social
media
the idea is that policy interventions
tend to focus on unitary explanations of
a phenomenon
there's some positive cause some idea
that if you intervene on that cause
through policy making say changing the
way that algorithms can work on facebook
changing the way that that twitter works
number of twitter followers someone can
have
whatever um that by intervening on that
particular variable
you're going to have some
clear impact
or influence on the the
thing that you're trying to change in
this case polarization
but if it's true that there are multiple
mutually compatible
independently sufficient possible causes
for polarization
and it's not clear that any single
explanation is going to suffice
and that means that policy interventions
that target a single cause
are not only um unlikely to succeed on
their own
but may even backfire because what you
need to be attentive to is the way in
which
um by trying to block one mechanism
which is actually present you can
unwittingly amplify another mechanism
which is also present just as an example
suppose you're the sort of person that
thinks that conformity
and um just you know poor connections
between different networks of people
this is
priya mentioned the filter bubble idea
but that's basically what's going on
um on this sort of proposal the idea
would be what's going on is that you
have
um you know people sometimes say a red
internet and a blue internet republicans
see some things when they go online
democrats see other things and they go
online they're updating on different
stuff
they're conforming with different groups
and it's by uh sort of separating
those that you end up with polarization
and so if we increased
the connections right showed more
democrats
more republican media and showed more
republicans more democratic media you
might think
what's going to happen is you're going
to have some convergence
well it could be that conformity and
these network effects
are playing a role but nonetheless trust
dynamics is also playing a role
in which case by exposing more exposing
people more to the other side
if they distrust the other side enough
it's either not going to make any
difference or may under some
circumstances even make
people tend to polarize more
um for instance using something like
uh um well
under some some modifications of the
trust dynamics can actually lead them to
polarize more and so what this means
practically speaking is that empirical
work
cannot be directed only to positively
identifying
uh specific causal factors right not
only to showing
that some factor is operative in some
context
but also to establishing what other
factors
are also operative and to weighing the
relative
causal contribution of the possibly many
different
causal factors now this is a much more
difficult kind of activity
and something that i think it's very it
you know
we don't have great methods to my
knowledge of of establishing
this kind of relative uh uh amount of
significance
but it seems to me that in a situation
like this where we have multiple
sufficient causes for a social
phenomenon
um and some reason to think that all of
them
may be present and may be important um
this is what we need to figure out
how to do in order to be able to
properly evaluate
any kind of policy proposal that's going
to be
successfully sensitive to the the full
complexity of the situation
thank you
thank you so much jim that was
absolutely fantastic
um and so i would like to uh
invite everyone to unmute and happiest
um yeah much to think about so
if i may before opening up the floor to
questions
uh ask you one myself
um i was just i mean i i really like
your caution
showing that there are many ways to
think about it but that we need to
really be
cautious about concluding that there's
one simple solution
or that we have captured the under you
know the actual
real-world polarization adequately
uh with any of these models uh to really
chase after one solution or the other
i think i wanted to come back to this
issue
that that you did raise in the beginning
and bring
in the work of dan kahan who is at the
center for cultural cognition at yale
where
you know he's been studying as you know
the sort of disbelief in climate change
and
science denialism so it sounds like you
know this
this landscape of priors that people
have
that you know these are informed by very
but by our tribal identities
and they are part and parcel
of a larger worldview so one of the
things he his findings often
show that you know there are sort of
these two broadish mindsets sort of a
more collectivist mindset and a more
individualist mindset and that this
mindset
is independent of one's position
on any one particular issue that is a
broad
lens with which people see the whole
world and therefore then every issue
gets refracted through that lens
so i was very curious um you know in
these modeling approaches you obviously
have room for priors and stuff but i was
curious what can if anything
be done about what seems like a
fundamental
psychological uh sociological schism
between personality types that is you
know very historically culturally
politically rooted
um and you know the same sort of
simplistic arguments have been about you
know east versus west collective versus
individual etc so i was very curious
how you would see that kind of
you know broader view of the world
institutions people etc
uh being folded into thinking about how
it sort of manifests
in polarization
um so i think i have
maybe two things to say um
one is that um
i see it as a kind of yes and sort of
situation
where um i think
you know each of the kinds of mechanisms
that i pointed to there's there's
psychological evidence that
that we engage in in this sort of
behavior that we do differentially trust
sources that we do prefer to conform
um there's psychological evidence
to support this idea of um
background either ideologies or perhaps
even something more basic about how we
think about
the world right i mean i think sometimes
in this literature it's not totally
clear that you can distinguish a case
where it's culturally constructed and
ideological and people sort of subscribe
to a set of beliefs
and a case where people actually
self-sort based on
um the strength of their disgust
reaction i mean so you see papers
like this saying well you know um
conservatives tend to have a stronger
disgust reaction or tend to have
different kinds of reactions uh to fear
to outsiders
it's sort of it's hard to know um i
think at this stage
uh other people may know more but it's
hard for me to know
um at this stage uh whether we should
think of that as cultural or
innate across individuals um but once
again it's something that
even if that weren't there other aspects
of human psychology seem to be
sufficient to explain polarization
um and so if we focus all of our
attention on uh trying to sort of
solve this underlying tribalistic
sort of tendency um i i think that we're
going to
to miss other things that are probably
also mattering right
that's one thing the second thing is
that um
i i have a kayla and i have another
paper together
where um we push back against some of
these ideas that
that the right way of explaining um
political tribalism is via some
organizing principle like
ideology which isn't exactly the same as
what you're describing but it's closely
related
um uh and so um george lachoff for
instance at berkeley has this idea that
there are two basic ideologies the
nurturing mother and the strict father
um and everyone falls into one or the
other so when you disagree about gun
control you disagree about
um you know coven you aren't disagreeing
about those things you're disagreeing
about whether
you you know the state should be a
nurturing mother or a strict father
um and we suggest that there are some
examples
where uh there appear to be correlations
between values or beliefs
that aren't really clearly explained by
this kind of
ideological explanation unless the
ideology becomes so vague
that really anything can be associated
with either of them
well i mean i guess but also you know
there's a tendency right especially in
western epistemology to be very
reductive
and have like dichotomies always break
things into dichotomy so it's like you
know it's either this or that
and there's like nothing sort of
interpolating in between so there's that
problem as well with that position
as well as what you are uh suggesting is
a
so there's a deeper problem with those
kinds of positions that are
uh very reductionist in some way right
reducing everything too
so what i would say though is i mean so
what we do in this paper is we we show
that actually
you can uh arrive at similar kinds of
correlations between beliefs
um with a kind of trust dynamics i see
where there's
no organizing principle it's entirely
endogenous and you get epistemic
factions where you have a whole bunch of
different beliefs totally unrelated
beliefs but where agents sort of clump
you know you've got all the ones who
believe action you know who prefer
actions a
a prime a double prime a triple prime
even they're totally unrelated
and then the ones that prefer b and b
prime and b double prime and so on
um without needing to introduce any kind
of
organizational principle um or
background ideology
or anything to sort of it just happens
via
a process where you know i agree with
you on gun control so i'm going to trust
your views about climate change and i
agree with you about that so i'm going
to trust your views about covet
and one example that we point to is um
and this is controversial but i really
like the example is uh
you know last march hydroxychloroquine
became the conservative treatment for
covid
and um uh rendezvir became the liberal
treatment
for kovid um at a
a point where there was far before there
was there was clear evidence
on it so you sort of you see this kind
of people sorting
into beliefs about matters of fact that
appear to depend on
their background you know other
background views but in a way i
i don't see any meaningful sense in
which hydro hydroxychloroquine is the
strict father
solution to covet and redesign is the
nurturing mother
solution to covet or the collective
versus anti-collectivist one it seems
like this is just something random
happened but they sorted
um so we have um
let me see um you can hear me right okay
so we have a question
uh from shinjeev kumar on the chat do
you think polarization per se
may not be problematic but the fact that
we have not developed a framework that
can
rationalize a pursuit for an underlying
unity of things
we don't say that our legs are polarized
so um there are two
two separate sorts of issues here one is
whether or not polarization is by itself
problematic
um and i think there are good reasons to
think that polarization is not
by itself problematic
especially if polarization is in in some
way
transient right so i think that there
are very good reasons to think
that um one reason why you might have
um mechanisms that slow down
learning and maybe preserve
transient polarization is because
it can take a long time to get reliable
consistent representative data
about the world and you know
a situation where you have for instance
different cultural groups
or even different individuals performing
different practices
and learning from those practices is one
perhaps where you can expect to achieve
better overall outcomes over time
and so you might think that that some of
the mechanisms that lead to polarization
are actually mechanisms that over the
very long run
benefit social learning or benefit
cultural evolution or something like
that
it may even have been um uh
you know in some sense selected for um
so i i don't think polarization by
itself is necessarily uh
problematic the idea though that um
some of these you know really quite
dichotomous
situations are these these propositions
where there's a lot of evidence
um and yet nonetheless there seems to be
a very long
uh and apparently quite damaging
disagreement um i i i don't want to
think
i i'm not i'm not i don't tend to think
that that the right way of thinking
about such situations is one where
um uh there really are just two ways of
being in the world and they're equally
right
or you know in a way suggested by this
um
uh idea that our legs are are not
polarized
our legs are chiral i mean i guess
that's a different
physics
um any other questions please feel free
to
type them into the chat
well at any rate i have another question
so i will
again take the liberty uh jim to ask you
so
um i i wondered um
whether you found that for
particular issues some
models were better descriptors
i'm not talking about the solutions
because i mean i think i totally take
your point that
you know it would be just too simplistic
to just say that okay let's this is the
model and therefore these are all the
solutions that can
describe how to mitigate the
polarization but i was curious so for
example
if you took um sort of the
polarization on the issue of vaccination
for example um
versus climate change um
did you did you find in the modeling
approach
that you know one set of models was like
a
better descriptor of the problem because
i think that's the point that you're
trying to make
that it's very hard to figure out and
restrict ourselves to
one unique model but i wondered
if there were particular kites you know
i'm just trying to see if there are ways
to
map particular issues to particular
kinds of agent models
um and whether you found that
uh whether there's something there that
you found interesting
for you know for matters that have to do
with you know personal being you know
like a
medical issue which has to do with our
personhood
uh much more immediate salience than
climate change which for many people
feels
like it's quite distant because they are
not accepting that it has touched us in
our lives already right so
i was just curious about like the the
proximity and you know what are the
other kinds of
um um
beliefs whether the beliefs can be
classified in some way
in terms of a particular model being a
better descriptor
um so uh to an extent
i mean i want to emphasize again that i
mean the models
here are um
are so simple uh that
i'm reluctant to confidently assert that
what's going on any of these models is
um what's going on in any particular
real world case
um that said uh
i do think that some of the qualitative
features
of the models do seem to
invoke particular cases particularly
well
and so for instance one of the things
that happens in the conformity model
is that you have a trade-off between how
much you care about successful action
and how much you care about conformity
now
normally when we present the model we
think about it in terms of the strength
of your preference that can form
um but another sort of dual way of
thinking about it
is the weakness of the benefits
of performing the successful action and
so
there are some sorts of cases where
although there is a matter of fact and
there is a lot of evidence available
nonetheless as an individual the
decisions you make
uh um aren't going to have particularly
strong effects one way or the other
um even you know there's polarization in
the u.s
regarding uh evolutionary theory
um again it's a case where there's an
enormous amount of evidence available
but there's absolutely nothing that hurt
like
there's no way in which you're
individually hurt uh going around and
doing things
as an individual that that uh are
incompatible with evolutionary theory
which for most people just means saying
i don't believe in evolutionary theory
that doesn't harm you in some way but
you do get the benefits perhaps of
conforming within
your community um climate change is a
bit like that because the consequences
of your action tend to be
remote in space and time right um
but other things like um you know
it it's harder to see
um some of the behaviors we've seen
around covet
as um an example
of um that kind of behavior
on the other hand i mean kayla and i
actually considered we didn't do it we
considered writing
a um
an op-ed describing how covet like
perhaps reflected just a complete
failure of classical decision theory
where
you you think that you can
um you know that people are motivated
right by immediate benefits or harms
right and so sort of directly seeing
this kind of behavior let's these kinds
of outcomes for these kinds of people
who are close to me i see it directly
that would affect your behavior but that
in fact it seems like other sorts of
considerations
um could counterbalance that kind of
direct immediate evidence
right especially now right i mean maybe
last march or april or may
you know you're not in new york you're
not in uh
um paris you know um
maybe you you don't trust the what
you're what you're hearing about
um but uh by now i think
people have much more direct experience
and yet many people still
are are act as if they're very skeptical
so um we have a question uh from jenny
wagner
is the timing of the update of
information
for each agent a critical issue imagine
you update information of the agents
asynchronously would that change the
behavior of the entire network
so there are a few different kinds of
effects here um one has to do with how
often uh agents perform their action
before sharing evidence right so you can
think about this as
how large a sample do you collect before
stopping and updating your beliefs
right because um when that's large uh
you know you're going to go with what
you originally think is the better
action you're going to gather a lot of
data and then you're going to reconsider
and you can think of that as a kind of
asynchronous updating because you aren't
updating every time you gather evidence
you're updating only
after a certain amount of evidence has
been gathered by each agent
and that absolutely changes uh
the um various things in in the models
it doesn't change the the qualitative
effects of these are the kinds of
outcomes and sometimes you get this and
sometimes you get that
but it does change things like the rate
at which agents learn
um which outcomes are more likely things
like that
um other kinds of asynchronous uh
learning might involve things like only
sharing every so often even though
you're updating more often
or um some agents share and other agents
don't
one thing that we look at is a situation
where
only some agents are able to gather
information uh and so some agents are
updating only on evidence gathered by
others
um we treat that as a situation where
say you have some policy makers we have
some scientists the policymakers are
updating on the scientist's evidence
um and
all of those sorts of things can can
have a an effect
um but they uh i think at the level of
description that i've i've given here
they don't matter to any of the results
that i've reported
great um so there's uh one other
question from tyler lutz
who is a former frankie fellow
might also be socially advantageous in
situations
in which truth itself for instance the
relative success of a versus b
changes with time do you have a sense of
how your models behave in such dynamic
circumstances
i have in mind here climate change in
particular in which most of us believe
that true distribution of climatic
phenomena is changing right before our
eyes
um so
uh i think that the answer
so we haven't looked at situations where
the actual um
uh uh success rates change i mean it's
an interesting modification to the
the model um but one that we haven't
looked at
um kevin zulman though one of his
earliest papers on network epistemology
uh really emphasize the importance
of what he called transient diversity of
beliefs but you might think also
as transient polarization um you know
and i mentioned this in response to
previous comment early on oh no no to
a an earlier question the idea that
under some circumstances
polarization may actually be beneficial
and
so kevin's suggestion there is that
basically if
instead of thinking of the um a
situation where
the actual outcomes uh change if you
think about a situation where
over time you you get access to new or
different kinds of evidence
um having people who continue to hold
the thing that seems incompatible with
the old evidence
means that they'll sort of pursue new
lines of evidence
and an example that he gives is the
discovery of the bacterial origins of
ulcers and so it turns out that there's
a bacterium called h pylori
that causes ulcers um the 19
but you know by the 1960s this the idea
of a bacterial cause of ulcers was
basically uh um
ruled out by a series of
really a small number of very
influential experiments that claimed to
have shown that
the stomach is um
uh antibacterial basically that there
aren't bacterial cultures in the stomach
and so you can't have a bacterial cause
of ulcers
um and you know one of the the
you know people stopped pursuing that
line of research except in australia
where they were just disconnected enough
from the rest of the research community
they had their own
sort of autonomous research program
going and they continue to explore this
possibility and eventually identify the
kind of bacterium that hadn't
been known before um
and uh you know we're able to establish
that in fact that is present in stomachs
and in fact it does cause
uh um uh ulcers you know the guy who
literally i was gonna say this is a
famous case where the experimenter
actually took right yeah he drank
glory he
took an antibiotic so he gave himself an
ulcer by drinking the h bilori and then
cured it with an antibiotic
and it's not clear what the epistemic
value of that is but it's certainly
i think desperation science right to
persuade yeah
um so i i guess if there are no further
questions um i would really like to
thank um jim for an excellent
thought-provoking talk and we really
look forward to
the discussion tomorrow uh with uh
professor weatherall and kevin doors so
at this point i just want to invite
everyone to
unmute and a clap
if possible thank you priya so much yeah
thank you so much yeah look forward to
seeing you tomorrow
yeah see you see you all tomorrow again
at 3pm
thank you and actually uh before i close
um i realized i wanted to do this at the
beginning uh
today is the first anniversary of george
floyd's
death so um i just wanted us to
remember that in closing